so I am going to talk about making text
effects with CSS and what I'm hoping
that you get out of today is not how to
make specific effects but how you can
combine new and existing CSS properties
to create interesting and more fun text
on the web and specifically editable
selectable and searchable text I don't
use SVG's I try and limit the use of
images although though there are some in
here but it's more about making proper
text that is good in the Dom and works
like any other website but in a really
nice fun and interesting way so before I
get into actually showing you some
examples there's two things that I
wanted to talk about the first is data
attributes these are really important in
creating text effects I don't use them
in all of the examples but they will
allow me to create layers for some of
the more complex text effects so I'm
going to show you today and the way that
they work is really simple basically you
add your data attribute on to your
heading or whatever HTML you want
attribute you want to use you always
prefix with data - and then you call it
whatever you want I've gone with heading
because that made sense to me and for
all of the examples I'm going to show
you today whatever you put in the h1 you
put in the data attribute and the reason
that I use these is one so I don't have
to duplicate my HTML because that's
messy secondly is because I'm not
duplicating my HTML this is much more
accessible so a screen reader isn't
going to read hello out three times it's
only going to read it at once which is
much better always important to think of
your users and the way that we're going
to use the data attribute normally it's
used to basically exchange information
between HTML and the Dom and what we're
going to do is allow the data in our h1
to be accessed by our CSS and we're
going to do that using pseudo elements
which is the second thing that I want us
to talk about
so pseudo elements basically act as
though they're part of the Dom even
they're not and they look something like
this in the HTML when you inspect it I'm
gonna focus on two for this which is the
before and the after you can use one or
both if you want to if you need them at
all
so the way that we're going to use these
is over in our CSS and it'll look
something like this so you use the
double colon syntax I'm using the before
here and you always have to include a
content property but instead of having a
hard-coded string or maybe an icon or
something like that we're going to use
the attribute CSS function and pass in
the name of our data attribute which is
started - heading and what that's going
to do is create a layout that I can use
that's exactly the same as my h1 that I
can sit over the top of my heading so
how can we use this I'm going to show
you how to make swip vertical outs with
CSS and what I will say is this very
specific first example works all the way
back to ie 8 so browser support is not a
problem with this one it's really really
easy to set up I'm just doing this in
code pen I hope you can see that I've
got my h1
with my daughter attribute at the top
here and then it's exactly the same in
my h1 as it is in my data attribute in
the CSS I'm going to set up my
background gradient it's 50% white 50%
black and I'm gonna get that which isn't
quite what we want but that's ok step
two set up the h1 now because I want the
text on the right hand side here to be
white what I'm gonna do is tell my h1 to
be white and I'm gonna add new space
white-space:nowrap the reason for this
is this specific example is single line
only so you'd have to do it for just
headings or very small text and that's
gonna give me this which is always what
we want the last step is setting up the
studio element so as you can see I'm
using it before just once to development
for this I'm going to apply the content
property with my daughter attribute
as the value I'm setting
position:absolute so that it sits over
the top of my text and a left offset of
zero the reason the left is in there is
when you start doing multi-line stuff
later they don't always align so it just
makes sure that it sits there good habit
and I'm going to set the color to black
because I want my text to be black on
that white side which not quite close
you might be honest I don't know if you
can on the projector but there's like
this little white outline that's because
the pseudo-element is sitting on top of
my white h1 so all we need to do is get
rid of that half of the black which we
do by setting a width of 50%
I don't know even flow of hidden really
easy and then we get this so as I say
this works in ia
so no excuses for fun editable
selectable searchable text on the web
these layouts were really popular like
three years ago I wish I'd done it then
so just as a quick rundown I really like
diagrams so I made you one the h1 is on
the bottom which is in white the
pseudo-element sits on top which is
black it's got a width of 50% and
anything over this side because I've set
overflow:hidden is just removed so
really really simple and easy to work
with now you can do all sorts of stuff
with this technique this is basically
the same except I'm using height instead
of width and I'm offsetting it with a
transform this is kind of an interesting
setup I've got my h1 which is the black
and then I put up a 4 on top with a
height the blue is just so you can see
it but actually what I'm doing is
setting it to white so it masks the top
half of the text and then I just add
another pseudo element and do a height
of 50 percent and an overflow of hidden
and offset it to the left and then I get
editable selectable searchable fractured
text which this one actually doesn't
work you're not yet but it does work in
i9 so there you go now you can do all
sorts of
stuff this is just using multiple colors
to create rainbow text I really like
this one I made this one too it only
works with five colors which is why it's
got my name in there this one was one of
the first ones that I made so I'm
particularly attached to it because it
kind of looks like the water is going
onto the beach Western Australia has
great beaches by the way if you ever
want to come visit you can also do
something like this all I'm doing with
this is rotating and reflecting it with
transform but it's just one h1 or this
if you're a designer is the Swiss design
poster that I try to recreate but I
didn't have the right font so if you do
know where I can get that please let me
know because I was kind of sad I
couldn't get it looking right but I did
like how I could just offset my two
pseudo elements to create the similar
kind of effect with just slicing it on
the bottom at different points so with
that in mind that works in a lot of
browsers all you need really is pseudo
element and data attribute support and
then if you use transforms you obviously
need transform support but it's pretty
versatile and you can do a lot of stuff
with it blend modes are another option
that you can add to kind of create some
dimension to your text effects sorry so
I'm going to show you how to make this
with blend modes we're gonna see it a
few times so it's very exciting what I
love about CSS is that there are so many
ways to do things you just have to have
a play around
sorry h1 again no Dada attributes don't
need them for blend modes because blend
modes are awesome all I'm going to do is
set my h1 to white like I did before and
set up my background gradient half white
half black and then we're going to add
the CSS property mix blend mode and
we're going to use the value of
difference and that gives me the effect
with basically one line of CSS and this
one is multi-line which is even better
now the way that mixed blend mode works
depends on the property that you use if
you're a designer and you use Photoshop
they're basically the same
you've got different exclusion
multiplied screen which I like a lot I
use that one a lot and you can pretty
much apply any of those effects but
because they're blending like the blend
color and the base color it means that
it matters what colors you're using so
if I change these to Rebecca purple and
sky blue it doesn't quite give me the
same effect because I'm trying to blend
the colors so it works really great with
black and white but not so much with
other colors so unless you're really
really awesome at Photoshop and
understand how all of the blend modes
work which I must admit I don't it's a
bit hard to get this to work the way
that you want with all the colors so you
just got to keep that in mind so support
is okay Chrome and Firefox Chrome and
Firefox is great Safari
supports a subset difference is
supported so if you want to do a black
and white layout you can use that in
Safari
edge is not supported last I checked but
it is coming soon I have seen lots of
tweets about that so that's awesome it's
never going to happen in IE so don't
worry about that that's what fall backs
are for and then nothing in the default
Android but chrome on Android does
support it so you can do all sorts of
stuff this is another Swiss design
poster or you can make something like
this this is like a mask this is over a
canvas so you can do it with video
images canvas whatever you want you can
do this I love this one it's like my
secret message very original text err
apologize or you can make this so you
can clip a background to the text or
what I love about this is that the text
shadow which is down here because I'm
blending it gets included in the blend
as well so it kind of like slowly fade
out I made this just after Christmas
holidays to try and remind myself to
relax when I was back at work writing
JavaScript
yeah what's great about this though is
that you can do this another way and
that's what I'm going to show you next
because blend modes again colors kind of
matter you can also do it using
background clip which is the next thing
I'm going to talk about you might be
able to see there's a animated gradient
going in the background there that's all
just CSS back to our trusty vertical
split layout know your data attributes
needed in the h1 because background clip
is also awesome exactly the same
background gradient as before 50% white
50% black but we're the difference we're
not going to change the color of the
font because we don't need to but I am
going to do is add a background gradient
into my h1 so instead of having it white
on the left and black on the right I'm
going to invert them because I want the
text on the white tube on the white
background to be black and the text on
the black background to be what and then
it's really really easy from here as you
can see just down the bottom here I'm
adding WebKit background clip to text
and it gets rid of my background again
not quite what we want and the reason
that this does this is because it clips
it to the text but the text has a fill
color by default so we have to get rid
of that if we want to be able to see the
background that's behind it and we do
that with another property called WebKit
text field color and we set it to
transparent
and voila and again this one is cool
because it's also multi-line which is
really really nice and what I love about
this one is that it actually doesn't
matter what colors you use because
you're not blending anything so you can
change it if Rebecca purple is my
favorite late named color and sky blue
it's just nice so yeah it'll work with
basically any color that you want it's
multi line so it's pretty versatile
supports actually pretty good
unfortunately background Clips like
fully supported
that's ie11 just to be clear I don't
know about a ten text field color in IE
though sadly no and not default Android
but with the new modern browsers that
effects pretty well supported so you can
really start using it now I think one
thing to note though you do have to use
the WebKit prefix because I think last I
checked all of the browsers had
implemented with that unofficial prefix
so that's weird but okay so you can make
something like this I leave this up on
my monitor at work sometimes because
it's quite relaxing it's like push I'm
actually just animating the background
not the text in this but I thought it
looked cool you can make mess I was
really proud of myself with this one
this was actually a Photoshop tutorial
which I remade in CSS and all it is is a
background gradient and some text
shadows for highlights along the bottom
here I'm so happy when I did this I did
this like three weeks ago like high-five
myself that's great or if you're into
Disney's frozen which I'm hoping some of
you are you can do this I made this a
week ago and I'm really happy with it
I put my name in it and I screenshot it
and I sent it to all my friends at work
because I love Disney so yeah this one
uses blend modes I'm using screen it's
got background clip I've got an animated
gradient
I've got text shadows everywhere there's
lots going on but it's
awesome now one thing that I did want to
say about this is this text effect is
not as cool without the frozen font
because you know it's part of the effect
so that I want to talk about fonts
specifically layered fonts now layered
fonts specially made fonts which are
made to be stacked so unlike just a
normal font where they've got like bold
and italic these ones are made with
different versions that you can stack on
top of each other and they're really
really really awesome and really easy to
use on the web are there's heaps of them
this one is called Strato by an
australian typography called sophie
brown so let's look at a simpler example
because that one had like five layers to
it but this one's really simple I'm
going to show you how to make this this
was the first one I made and still
attached to it as a result we're going
to set up our h1 now I do need data
attributes for this but again support
for this is excellent all the way back
to a nine if you use two pseudo elements
or ie if you use just one so this one
works in a a movie now set up our h1
what's important here is that I do have
set the font family and this front is
called core circus and it has lots of
different layers that you can use and
different versions of the font I'm going
to set my font weight to normal because
I don't want a each one to inherit the
bold from the heading and then I've just
got my color in there and that gives me
boring normal text step two is adding
the pseudo element and much like my
example earlier I've got my content
property and my data attribute is the
value I've got it set over the top with
position absolute it's got a left offset
of zero and instead of blending it or
clipping it or you know you're cutting
the width off what I'm going to do is
set a different font family and in this
case I'm using course circus 2d dot one
they're a bunch of different versions in
this one and that with the color of
white is going to give me perfectly
layered dots over my text
which is almost the effect the next part
is a text shadow which is this I'm
actually going to show you how to do
this if you're not familiar with text
shadows so this is going to be fun so
I'm going to show you how to make this
first bit which is actually a white key
line around the text so let's not do it
in code and just have a diagram because
I think they're easier so it's really
really really easy and once you
understand how text shadows work it
opens up lots of opportunities so
basically a text shadow has a horizontal
and vertical offset a blur and a color
so in this case I'm going minus four
pixels horizontally and minus four
pixels vertically I'm not going to do a
blur for any of these because I want a
solid color and then I'm just gonna set
the color to black for demo purposes and
you can see here it's just done this
sort of top edge so then we add another
one and we do plus four horizontal minus
four vertical and you can kind of see
how these are joining up now and we just
do that two more times
we do down the bottom with minus four
and plus four which gives me this bottom
edge with the green and then all we have
left here is is tiny a little bit in the
corner so we just fill that in with
another one and now we've got a
perfectly outline text and that was that
first part you can see here it's not
quite perfect doesn't really matter that
much because if this was one pixels it's
not very noticeable it looks like this
this is whether in blue so you kind of
can't tell in the corners that it's not
quite there and most of the time people
just skip over that so there's this bit
which is as easy as the other one I'll
show you how to make the first part all
I'm doing here is making my 3d shadow
move off to the right so I'm going four
pixels horizontally and not vertically
then I do four pixels vertically and not
horizontally
then this one is where I start putting
in the sort of 3d aspect where it starts
to look like it's coming off the page
instead of doing four pixels I'm going
to do five pixels horizontally so you
can see its got like a step and then
four pixels down to fill up this little
gap here and you basically just repeat
that over and over again until you reach
the desired distance from the text that
you want so it's like one zero zero one
two one one two three two two three and
so on until you get as far as you want
away from the text I've gone up to like
sixty pixels before it's a really big
text shadow but it's super cool so one
thing to note lade fonts often do
include the 3d layer in the font the
reason that I use a text shadow is one
don't use a font for something you can
recreate in CSS it's bad for performance
because you start loading loads of fonts
she says right before she shows you an
example with five fonts in it but
nevermind
and also you only get two pseudo
elements to work with so you don't want
to waste your layout on something you
can remake with like a line albeit a
long work line of CSS so kind of try and
use whatever you can in CSS before going
back to a font so this is kind of how it
looks it's I just added this in last
week I'm really happy with it I did it
for all of my examples for layered fonts
so get ready so as you can see we've got
the dots this solid text which is just
our normal h1 and then the text shadow I
put on a separate layer so you could see
kind of how it was set up so it says
yaki by Nova type no very type I just
add a really awesome because they gave
me all their licenses for free for my
demos because it would have cost me a
lot of money to buy them all so they're
great use their fonts
this is another version of course circus
except I'm using a line and this has
like heaps of tech shadows in it like
all over the shop I like this one this
one is festive or letters again lots of
text shadows this one is called wonder
which is also very very type yes so
great not subtle plug and this one is
this one's actually my favorite this is
red shaded by a typographer called Jamie
Clark and this is five layers of his
font because it's just so beautiful I
love his 3d shadow and you know the sort
of dot bits so wicked this font is
really nice to work with as well because
everything's like perfectly aligned I
love this I actually had to put a span
in my h1 with a data attribute to get
the extra two layers of this but is
worth it
although five font loads later maybe
like as a responsible web developer I
don't recommend you do that often maybe
like subset it to just the letters you
need so fonts are pretty awesome and
they're really amazing and because
performance is a thing the other fonts I
wanted to talk about a variable fonts
because they're kind of new and I don't
know how many people have read about
variable fonts and put basically they're
a special font file that contains
multiple versions of a font in the one
file and this is really great for
performance because you're only loading
one font not multiple but it's also
great for us because they're kind of
special in this example you can see I'm
animating between like a thin and a
thick version of the font and that's
just one front file there I'm not doing
anything fancy it's not an SVG and the
way that it works is they have an axis
and you define like your narrow version
here and then like a big thick one over
here and it interpolates between the
thin version and the thick version and
that means that we can animate from this
point to this point which is pretty cool
of course if you add another axis like
width you've also got a sort of
condensed version and a really wide
version and you can keep adding access
points I think it's like 64,000 don't
quote me on that but I pretty sure I
read that and they're a bunch of
predefined ones like with weight and
slat but also the font creators can make
their own versions so they can just
create all these kind of quirky
interesting variable fonts that we can
then animate with CSS so I'm just going
to mention support before I show you
demos because I don't want you to get
excited and then be like really sad
Chrome awesome Safari great Firefox sad
nealy apparently I think they're working
on it edge is really close to I think
which is great I think I saw like a
tweet yesterday about it no that was
Firefox yeah
tweet yesterday from Firefox so that's
cool again II's not ever gonna happen so
that's okay we can move on eventually
from ie edge is pretty good they're
doing a lot of cool stuff and a default
Android sadly no but again that's what
fall backs are for so this was the first
example I made and I'm not gonna linger
on it too much because I was really
disappointed with it this is literally
all I had like two weeks ago to show
four variable fonts and I was sitting at
home with my cup of tea just thinking oh
it's so boring no one's gonna be excited
about variable fonts with this so I made
this one instead and I really loved this
one so two weeks ago this did not exist
so there you go I'm really really happy
with that so I'm going to show you how
to make it really easy I've got my h1 I
forgot to take the content editable bit
out all that does is allow me to edit
the text in koi pen so don't worry about
that I'm using a data attribute I don't
need it for the variable fonts just for
making the text look like grass so not
needed for variable fonts but is needed
for background
clip so this is what it kind of looks
like in the boring version I just wanted
to show front face because it is a
normal font
it's called deco by regular 24 and we
set it up like we normally would with a
front family and then we use this
special front variation settings and
every axis in a variable font has a four
digit like code associated with it in
this case it's called inline which is
this first one and this one is called
skeleton worm which I thought was a
great name and we're going to use these
to make the grassy bits and we need both
because I kind of hacked the font a
little bit to make this work
so first I'll show you what in line
looks like that's in line looks like
that which is kind of cool let's get rid
of that and skeleton worm looks like
little knobbly squarey bits like this
but if you combine them they look like
little pointy leaves which I found out
as I was playing with it yes I know
exactly what I'm going to do this so add
an animation really simple it kind of
just infinitely looks like it's growing
in out it's a little bit junky but it's
new and it's really easy to set up I'm
just going starting from zero thousand
and down to zero first skeleton women
just in and out constantly the rest of
it is really just all stuff I've shown
you before I added a background image
and then I'm just going to put my
background clip and text full color in
as well
to make sure that the image clips to the
text really easy that's kind of cool
it's not great so let's just chuck in a
heap of text shadows cuz I love text
shadows yes alright and then I'm going
to add in two pseudo elements with more
text shadows and that gives me this
which is cool because it looks like a
hedge and it's grass and there's leaves
everywhere and just to make sure you're
all aware that it's editable it's just
normal searchable text
it's really cool you might have noticed
that the exclamation mark doesn't have
the little growing bits and that's
because the font creator didn't add it
on the special characters so fonts
matter in this case
maybe they'll add it now that they've
seen the the cool example that I made
them so you can do all sorts of stuff
this one I really like this is deck of
irregular as well except it's a
different variant and what I love about
this is that because the font itself is
getting read of parts of the font in the
glyphs the text shadow disappears with
it as well because the tacks shadow is
added on to the text so when the text
disappears so it is a text shadow one
area of concern with this is in chrome
there's a bit of a memory leak with the
animation so your computer might explode
eventually so don't leave it open if you
go look at the code pen I have been told
though that they are working on fixing
it so yay
soon this this text shadow is really
long by the way I think it's like 80
pixels or something it's just like blows
out to nothing it's great I love that
one this one is basically using blend
modes and background clip and variable
fonts and all sorts of stuff going on
there I've got gradients and everything
I'm quite fond of this one this one is a
cat emoji in a font what is interesting
about this font is it's called I think
it's as icon something like that and it
was made like 10 years ago for a
different spec of variable fonts and
they just basically reboarded out for
variable fonts and all this is is a cat
emoji and then in the font variation
settings I'm just specifying either the
cat standing up and I'm animating
between the two and it's got like
turtles and ours and a little like man
riding a bicycle it's really cool I
highly recommend you go check it out
there's a great website called access
praxis where you can play with all the
variable fonts and this one's on there I
personally like the owl
do you like shrugs it's really subtle
don't be interested to see if icon fonts
become a thing again like everyone's
kind of shifted a lot to SVG but because
our variable fonts are offering this
kind of thing it'll be interesting to
see if that shifts back again the way
the web does so the last thing that I
wanted to talk about is clip path and
the reason I wanted to mention this is
because it kind of opens up a lot of
opportunities for layouts as well as
just text and the way that it works is
it allows you to specify a particular
region to show rather than like just
cutting off a width or a height and you
can do all sorts of different shapes
with it so you can make stars or hearts
or like angular a text like this one and
it's animal eatable as well so you can
animate it over different things I'm
going to show you how to make this which
is a variation of our split vertical
layout it's multicolored it's multi-line
and it's really really easy to do so
we're gonna set up our h1 we are gonna
use a Dyna attribute for this and then
we set up basically our h1 with our font
the color which is like that cream color
and then the two pseudo elements because
I'm going to use both because it's got
three columns in it again I've got my
content property with my data attribute
as a value I'm that's actually not
needed I apologize it doesn't need to be
there a position:absolute we're going to
set as well so the text sits on top and
we need top and left set on this because
it's multi-line sometimes if you don't
set those values they miss a line and it
looks weird
so make sure you add those in I think
it's because of the margin on the h1 I
just chopped them in because it's easier
that's very lazy don't listen to me
there so then we're going to set up the
h1 using the after and we're just going
to get this little bit over here and
it's pretty simple we just set our color
which is this random hex value and then
clip path our clip path has a bunch of
different
syntaxes depending on what kind of shape
you want to make with it I'm going to
show you how the polygon works because I
think it's the most versatile but if you
were doing a circle for example you just
define a radius the polygon is really
simple it works in reference to the
container that it's in so if you have a
look over in this corner here you can
see I've got a container and then we're
going to define this orange shape here
on each of these red points coincides
with a coordinate point inside the
polygon syntax so we start off with our
top left point which is 70% from the
left of the container and 0% from the
top so there then we've got a hundred
percent from the left and zero percent
from the top a hundred percent from the
left and a hundred percent from the top
which is this bottom one and then 70
percent from the left and a hundred
percent from the top which is this one
here so it's quite simple and that gives
us a rectangular shape to use on our
effect which is just here and as you can
see it only defines the region that I've
specified everything else is clipped out
so we do the same thing with the before
except we're going to define this point
in the middle which is 30 percent from
the left and 70 percent away another 3
percent away from the the far right edge
I'm not going to go through this
step-by-step but it is essentially the
same it's just a different set of
coordinate points 30 and 70 and you just
do exactly the same thing so it's quite
easy to work with and that gives me this
middle region with my sort of greeny
color and because the h1 is already the
color that we want I don't have to do
anything with it we just leave that bit
as is and that gives you the effect
which is multiline and you can do all
sorts of stuff with it now our support
for clip path is a bit weird
the yellow means partial support it
basically means that you can't use
external SVG's in the clip path but this
effect that I just showed you works fine
in Chrome and Safari Firefox awesome
edge is coming soon again not going to
happen in IE I apologize and also our
default Android browser no support but
chrome don't support it on Android so I
wanted to show you this because it's
really simple you can just like lay this
stuff and chuck shapes in wherever you
want there's a great website
I always forget the URL it's like if you
Google clip here and then clip path
it'll come up and it's got stars and
hearts and you don't have to work it out
yourself and just copy and paste I go
there all the time
and that's where I got this from it's
like a cross or you can do the fractured
text on an angle because you can make
like easy diagonal shapes this is
exactly the same setup as the one
earlier but it's got clip path in it
instead of a height you can make
something like this this is my abstract
art it uses blend modes as well I like
this one a lot for some reason whenever
I put this up back in Perth people
always take a picture of me standing
next to it with the word crazy on the
slide I don't don't know what you can
also do something like this so you can
bend it around a corner this is kind of
an optical illusion I've got a gradient
on one side that kind of looks like a
corner and then I'm just like
transforming the text and skewing it so
it kind of looks like it's bending
I like this that's cool you can do
something like this
this is using clip paths for a gradient
on the font
oh sorry background clip on the font but
the little Chevron is the clip path so
as I animated across the text it reveals
the colors below it's also originated by
Jamie Clark with another version of his
like dottie 3d thing that's cool or you
can also use it to create magazine based
layouts for the web like this one you
can do similar stuff like this with that
very first example but it's a lot harder
and you're more restricted Plus this is
better from a responsive perspective
because as the text drops onto a new
line the clip paths just like works
and we'll cut the new part of the text
or you can do something like this so the
way that this works is my clip path is
just defined around the dress and
anywhere that sits on top of this is
white what's really interesting about
this effect is once I made it and put it
up on code pen our CSS tricks wrote an
article about it and how you could do it
another way without clip paths using
blend modes and filters so if you're
interested in doing something like this
definitely go check it out because they
like compared a whole bunch of methods
it's very thorough much more thorough
than I am
it's really good check it out and the
last one that I wanted to show you is my
favorite and that's this one this was a
Photoshop tutorial that I remade last
January in CSS and if you did ask me a
year ago if this is possible I would
have said no if any designer had given
me this to build because I should add
I'm not a designer I'm a developer I
would have been like you are crazy I
can't make that in CSS but as it turns
out you can this uses clip path for the
bottom the height example on the top and
just a h1 is the pink with a bunch of
text shadows there's also a hippo
transforms in this as well what's great
about this is when I shared it on
Twitter a bunch of people came back with
me and ways to do this differently like
there was one using a line height hack
so you don't have to use clip paths so
that means it works in anything that
supports transforms there was another
example using the 3d perspective and
clipping on the 3d plane which I thought
was very creative so I guess when you're
playing around with CSS just remember
that just because I've done it this way
doesn't mean you can't do it another way
a CSS gives us a lot of things to work
with it's hugely powerful and all you
have to do is kind of experiment and
play around and see what you can come up
with and if somebody tells you that it's
not possible it might just be that
nobody's trying
and everyone's just assumed that you
can't make folded Photoshop text in CSS
when the reality is you can and you can
make it selectable and accessible and
searchable and editable and you can have
a really awesome beautiful website
instead of something super boring so on
that oh I'm gonna finish up thanks so
much I hope you've been inspired I hope
you go and play with CSS and make some
cool things and one thing I do want to
leave you with is because it's all text
you can play with emojis with this and
make new emojis this is one I made
called winky cap and if you go on my
code pen there's like poop nado and
emojis with glasses and crowns and all
sorts of things so because it's all just
text anything that's text it applies to
including emojis so thanks very much
[Applause]